I see 27.8 me to see who wants to give
me a thumbs up on that thumbs up lots of
times up thinking hands down thumbs down
okay just before we do parse it because
not everyone here get thumbs up 27.8
like where is that come from because I
haven't actually written it all four
sides on FML ok lovely so you can see
okay um what was it by the way how did
mention something that um we all could
see but what's the clue that tells us
why this is 9.1 me there's a little tiny
thing on there yes he's limping as you
remember I've told you many times about
how famously lazy mathematicians are to
tell you that those signs the top and
bottom lines are the same and of course
these ones as well we want to put as
little notation on there as phosphorus
so you get there the same your double
looks good okay we'll pause on number
two because it seemed like there was
some controversy about that let's come
to number three now there's a curveball
in number three there's actually trying
to care for all versions what's the
curveball number three yeah that's
sneaky right so I'm calling you back to
last time when we said if you've got
units in one for you want them to talk
to other kinds of units what did you
need to do someone else would have
thanked us with someone else safe yeah
Nikhil I'll patch in during the second
TV it does garish okay
okay now can I just pause for a moment
porsche moment Ramesh is suggesting i
think is a great suggestion that we
convert this to centimeters now that's
not the only thing you could have done
what year what if you didn't want to
convert this what other approach could
you have taken yeah yeah great like
there's nothing that told I didn't tell
you in the question give it to me in
this unit for that puter I just said
tell me the perimeter the link all the
way around so you could have given it an
eye of the unit now can anyone tell me
just further on why is religious
suggestion I think a great idea do that
one round the other one there are at
least two reasons I can think of
Christian what do you have to do lesson
alone I can't remember one there's only
one to convert and secondly there's
something else you can dodge if you
leave these in centimeters what else
becomes sort of simpler if you leave
them as they are just like add them
together then you don't have to worry
about kg at the end ok so I mean I could
have still added them and left them as
meters that would have been okay can
someone tell me like say this guy over
here 38 centimeters what is that in
meters 0points 0.38 okay and then this
would be 0.45 and then this would be 0.4
which is all fine but it's decimals like
I prefer to deal with yeah you had right
I prefer to your whole numbers because
just easier for my brain and I'm simple
for the numbers okay all right number
two seems like there are some questions
marks over this can someone and someone
like to give me and alternatives I'm not
saying what's right or wrong well yeah
come up 62 ok now I'm going to put a
question mark on beat hmm now
interestingly before I want you to think
think back like the AMC remember when we
did that competition most of us didn't
and sometimes you got to get questions
and you're like I don't obviously know
what the answer is yeah they don't seem
to have given me enough information now
interestingly even though i don't know
whether which one of these is right or
even if either of them right they could
me wrong I think 62 not having done any
calculations is probably a better answer
than 59 now think think think think and
I'm going to ask you to get back to the
clueless as well gave you last week what
clue tells me even without even touching
any of these numbers and adding or
anything like that or multiplying how
the way what is my instant tell me that
makes 62 a better answer than 59 okay it
has to be larger than like 44 plus 18
okay where did you get 44 and 1800 sorry
oh it's because the thing at the top
that theme has to go outwards okay so
the reason why we have like specific
words in our mathematical terminology is
because I knew it when you don't have
them you end up calling things things
and stuff in the place with the circuit
what's happening here you have here a
corner that's kind of been chopped off
right is that sort of a reasonable way
to describe this it's like there was a
rectangle there was a rectangle but then
someone took a weird rectangular bite
out of it okay now obviously that
changes the area we'll talk about area
today what effect what change does it
have for the perimeter think primitive
what how much does it change having
taken this chunk outta breath it doesn't
change the perimeter at all does it have
a look think about where the original
rectangle was right when you cut this
part off you created a new leg over here
right which has the same leg right there
they're the same and in the same way
when you chopped up this part you
created a new leg over here which again
these guys are matching does that make
sense now here's the thing you got a
parallelogram you're a rectangle or
something like a rectangle remember what
fabulous at the beginning what did you
do with the 9.1 in the 4.8 what did we
do with these numbers before adding the
other we here we doubled the right why
did we double flow is doubling a common
sense
yeah good there's like two double to
double your going to do the same thing
over here for the rectangle these are
all whole numbers when you double a
whole number I don't care what whole
number you start with it you're going to
end up with something even okay now this
is not a crazy number like this is in
the ballpark is it what's it missing and
why can someone tell me cuz like it's
very very close yeah okay so i've been a
bit sneaky you're gonna rub this off
again and then we'll finish off because
I'm 62 is the run it's a good job um
what's think about this question see how
there was on a conversion here that was
sneaky the thing that stinky here is
there's a link that's missing I haven't
told you i would like given a label on
it this guy over here but you can work
it out cut you okay because these two
legs are still going to be 22 all up and
these two links are still going to be
nine all up okay which is why I 62
months as enemies Allah is great so it
comes up what's that